я володимир перлів луганський партизан
ромадин україни тяжко поранений у 2015
був заручником терористів луганську я
герой України хочу звернутися до
президентові України
пан володимир зелінський на свою
передвиборну програму ви зі своєю
командою вийшли з претензій та вироком
Петру Порошенку про те, що він обікрав
народ армію та бюджет україни ваша нова
влада озвучила своє головне гасло
прийде весна садитимемо на тих виборах
я дуже часто був у регіонах і можу
підтвердити, що саме це нав'язана
телебаченням почуття якоїсь образи за
пограбування всього народу та ще й
час війни дуже відштовхувала
виборці від Петра Порошенка
як я так і ці українці та всі ми ми
чекали і чекали коли нам покажуть ці
розслідування
звинувачення щодо курортів та відповідно
рішення судів на це
так звана анонсована вами
злодійство пройшло вже дві весни але не
те щоб суден і посадок навіть
офіційної підозри негайно я
побачив цю адресу порошенка не можуть
знайти нічого не крадіжок не так званого
мародерство
натомість ми бачимо спробу вручити
підозри порошенка за якісь його
дії пов'язані з сумнівним
порушенням процедури призначення зам
начальника зовнішньої розвідки, що це фан
президент цілий рік dvr і все
правоохоронні органи працюють над
справою однієї людини і це на той час
коли країна стоїть перед серйозними
проблемами в корупції в економіці
протистояння Росії вам не вийшло
довести що порошенко щось вкрав так
саме тому ваш рейтинг впав до цих
38 відсотків народ все більше і більше
бачить що його швидше за все обманювали
щоб бути йде далі за арештами та
в'язницями ви почнете розстрілювати
позицію та протестувальників але у нас не
Росія ні іран і не північна корея з
українцями так не вийде це вже
перевірено ми не забули якій кількості
крові привело
мовчазна байдужість народу в судовій
розправі над опозицією за часів
януковича
а лінуйтесь і подивіться на який шлях ви
станьте пани президент прошу вас
припинити тиск
звільненнями на прокурорів та
слідчих припиніть
підштовхувати махінаціям та маніпуляціям
правосуддя за все за це доведеться
відповідати всім
подумайте
[музика]